right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 24 and
it's another glorious Sunday and I'm
extremely excited to introduce our
special guest today so let's get right
into it I want to introduce a Lord who I
had the pleasure of meeting in the flesh
at this year's Guardian column his
videos are always passionate highly
informative and sometimes very critical
of topics most youtubers are afraid to
comment on while some may incorrectly
label his views as hate this Lord fights
the good fight for the gaming community
while also providing solution to these
issues and contributing with some of the
list fan-made exotics you ever see in
destiny introducing the Luna shooter
champion the feel is non corporate
member of the Destiny community and the
Lord who always hold you accountable in
his comment section Marvin Lord cactus
HD how are you doing sir now doing well
does a quite the intro there really the
only destiny youtuber I know that does
not care what I mean I'm a little tired
I was up to like for him but I'm
powering through I decided to do this
let's go let's go alright nice and of
course we have the usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the Como's my brother
from another mother and the non agro
gamer himself
my main Lord addict how are we doing sir
pretty good I've worked all night shift
got three hours of sleep so I'm pretty
much the exact same boat as HD I go like
six hours of sleep so everybody's power
went through a lot of fights lastly a
lot of stuff and of course our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single-player experience
Semmy offline Xbox profile Illuminati my
red what suffering are we doing sir
do a fantastic fantastic man I'm in the
same boards everybody else a lot of
combat sports last night and just
watching a lot of press conferences a
lot of tears flowing so you know and of
course the excess gamer oh the Lord who
was a man of his convictions and demands
nothing less than the premium experience
he loved it Lord King how are we doing
sir we're doing fantastic 720 917 was a
wonderful day for combat sports it was
it should be marked on your counter
there should be a holiday it was so
fantastic yeah no it was a UFC was
awesome was the fact that I said combat
sports but another individual understand
that you wanna underline the UFC and
fantastics be you sir that you watched
your combat sport you watched UFC that's
fantastic while other people in the
world actually 2.3 million people viewed
showtimes experience with Adrien Broner
versus Garcia it was fantastic
Wow 500,000 people purchased the you'll
see the numbers have spoken you have
been voted out always fighting a good
fight for boxes on the ILP not telling
you what you want to hear or what you
need and of course we got another great
little show lined up so I want to first
before we get into it or we do our
normal what the Lords are playing but I
want to get to a little cactus because I
gotta get his gaming history like where
did this magical journey start for you
before you became one of the biggest
destiny youtubers in these streets I
mean geez
I began for a while but like a long
while but interpreting YouTube like I
started with or
I think you know a lot of people started
when back in the day like I've been
doing YouTube for Oh must be years now
the first one of the first videos I
posted on might like the kazoo detail
was modern warfare 3 so that came out a
while ago and I had a channel before
that that I was posting battlefield 3
and mono 4 - so yeah I was like I did
called to be for a while I was black ops
2 actually did okay you look at black
ops 2 like I was a you know the classic
smaller call of a new youtuber found
modest success then I switched into
Borderlands yeah that was kind of the
start of the looter shooter nice job or
laps to videos like that was pretty that
was pretty fun and then for some reason
um
switched into battlefield 4 and Wool it
was a time between Borderlands 2 and
destiny where I was just doing
battlefield 4 like I was a battlefield 4
youtuber and actually had like
reasonable success in that um this but
then yeah then switched into destiny and
and I've been doing destiny ever since
is except for like it was a little bit
of a time where I was covering the
division pretty hardcore yeah that
seemed then the April update came out
which is really good actually so when
went back in a kind of stop doing
division I'm sure when Bungie saw you
jumping back on the the Destiny train
they're like yo we did something good h
DS playing our game well what was the
April day was quality like it was did
add a lot of good stuff like I had
noticed complete complain out there I'm
when something good happens I'm I'm more
than willing say this is good they
[ __ ] it was good
remade the prison a bunch of new weapons
bunch of new armor like a just so much
before the prison was what how do we
think I logged into destiny for that
activity yeah I I beat it
in one day in one match like at let's
plays a friend and we we did like five
matches and we got both the go shells so
we're like alright
there it is done I don't know it was got
a kind of light on the content side
though that so when you said you know
with the Borland's and stuff like that
was kind of like your early beginnings
my question is for us like on on a
console like what was the first console
heck is HD was your first one dude I
wasn't I wasn't like oh gee way back
with like like n64 is whoever cuz my
parents were like convinced that video
games would like ruin me turns out
laughing now but I started with like a
Gamecube that was my that was my first
choice I owned GameCube and I had like
called it II finest hour which was lit
and like many stuff absolutely cool take
it in back lit room and I was a great
system absolutely and of course this
week was Lords been playing we'll start
with a Lord addict which what's been on
the radar this week far as what your
games plan actually for once I'm gonna
come in here and tell you guys I have
not played a Halo Wars to one and then
lie and say yeah I kind of missed the
destiny to bed ankle I I don't know why
but I was really getting down on that
multiplayer but we'll get into that
later I've been playing a lot of Fable
fortune and some games being a kid have
been playing on Steam I can't really
talk into that a whole lot but besides
that you know I've been having a decent
week on games Oh real quick before I
pass it over home look a kiss on the
chat was to know first of all how old
are you
because a lot of them are saying
GameCube was their first system you know
I'm 24 so nice like there is there was
people earlier than me I remember like
going to friend's house and playing on
BB was again keep I remember going to
friend's house and like playing non-stop
that
Pokemon game where you could take
pictures of pokémon pokémon Safari oh
yeah so for example absolutely like that
I think what it what a dumb game please
go around taking pictures of that was
the game you know what's funny you know
what's funny that's that's the most
requested game to bring Breck from the
n64 era I'm now gave my suite I remember
that absolutely so also best I just got
a point us out shout out quickly best um
like movie franchise game ever was lure
the rings to return the King on the
Gamecube oh oh my goodness
dice dice alright listen
it was very Friday like look at the
young buck dominating night they're very
proud of you right there look at because
they loved you right as far as what else
the law has been playing so Lord
sovereign which you've been touching
this week I finally be getting into some
splatoon - um yeah playing some of the
single-player campaign I'm out when I'm
I would my my Wi-Fi sucks so I can't
really get on and play on it but I'd
love to play some salmon runs and I
haven't been able to do it yeah I think
it's stupid that they limit it and they
just need to do it in exactly and then
actually touching the the pile of shame
I want that you started playing some Far
Cry 3 actually the Ubisoft guy and for
whatever reason I never just sat down to
play and I'm probably ten hours in and
it's yet it's kind of that crack like
it's really really good very good know
them and the Lord King or whatever I've
been trying to break away from my xbox
so I've been down in the man cave yeah
my polish a my PlayStation 4 games I
stepped away from the VR and I got into
Call of Duty
Wow I mean Oh
the stuff that people was talking about
how bad Call of Duty was I just took it
out the rap I brought it you know what
when I got it when you know when it came
out the game looks great and HDR
beautiful one smooth place fantastic
story line is so good that you got kind
of McGregor and you got Jon Snow in it I
mean go back in it you have many people
and there's so many actors with their
faces and their likenesses and it feels
just like a big-budget movie it's a
great game I'm not gonna front I listen
to what everybody was saying like how
soft and battlefield was so much better
okay yeah isolated alone the game is
beautiful run smoothly plays great I
love it I can't say too much about it
it's nice for me she's been a been a fun
week I've been trying to get the backlog
done obviously you know like a lot of
addict had said you know the destiny to
beta oh man I had had to control my my
urges and not played as much because I
really would getting into the PvP so
I've been actually working on my backlog
I've been starting you tell took my
telltale games I'm actually started the
Walking Dead the new season but now I
touch that a little bit we got a little
second 7 in this week with the crew the
rest of our free weekend in titanfall
I was actually I dusted off shout out
the Lord demon they asked me to do the
frontier defense which is kind of like a
horde mode which I just dropped it's a
lot of fun y'all
I mean for those who are the fence were
titanfall I mean when Xbox is a free
weekend playing weekend I don't know if
it's as well as PlayStation go soft help
me out I'm not sure but oh yeah I'm not
sure of this but I know Xbox for sure
has a free play weekend and let me tell
you I forgot how good that game was I'm
like you know what you get it brought
the fever back into your point looking I
can't wait for the when the Xbox one
acts and stuff like that it gets the
treatment so to speak yeah the game
looks phenomenal now so that's pretty
much it the free weekend is on
everything PCP is good for them good for
them because they needed to promote this
game and what I'm hoping happens it's
kind of like a rainbow 6 siege
resurgence where memo and rainbows
kind of didn't jump out the gate
initially with sales and stuff like you
know so I'm what I'm hoping is that you
know now this kind of this free weekend
gets people to fever they capture and
they actually pick up the game and it's
a great game it just came out at the
wrong time I think the EA because
there's gonna be an EA access soon so I
think that the fact that once it hits EA
access I think the numbers are going to
pick up astronomically from that
standpoint you know for five dollars a
month or how much you pay for the air
for it I mean the game for EA access
Xbox has a goldmine there absolutely so
we're gonna get into actually the poll
results so last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken
the winner of the Xbox one X treatment
poll at a close 56 percent is the Y
weight group the people have said they
don't want to deprive themselves of
games like destiny to shadow of war
Assassin's Creed's origin and even force
a seven so those who will wait for
November seventh that a group was about
44% so it wasn't a complete blowout but
the people have spoken and thanks to
over 120 plus people are participated in
that Arlo podcast Twitter poll and
laughter we got a new one cooking up at
in but a real quick with the Lord's door
thought about that people are not may
back in wait for the Xbox it back on my
back burning I'm gonna play the game and
then when it gets the 4k they don't come
out as purchasing like if it's if it's
there's gonna be purchased like it'll be
sitting in my queue but like Lord King
said like destiny yeah nobody wait on
destiny go play destiny but everything
else like the single play experiences
yeah I can wait a week or so to play it
on the xxo whether it's purchase than
that at that you know at point of the
day that it launches it's another
question but again that's not a big deal
now look hack is real quick
now as far as the Xbox 1x I know right
now you're playing I believe you're
playing on PlayStation correct yeah okay
cool
now obviously we know that the the PC
version and the specs came out and we
know all that you know amazing 60 frames
uncapped all that good stuff are you at
least tempted to to make the jump as far
as uh you can take there well I mean if
it's 60 frames no I'm uh I'm going to
get destiny 2 on the PC I've got a good
pieces I'm a hundred percent I'm pretty
sure to get destiny 2 on the PC but I'm
also already pre-ordered the digital
deluxe edition on the PlayStation 4
because obviously I can't wait a month
was still alone Ted to play the game
like that's that's devastating for me
right like I just can't be like oh you
guys in a month all my exotic weapon
guides then like obviously I can't do
that so um first one to the punch that
station is really important and also
it's got the exclusives which is a which
is a thing so I'll just I'll just rock
both see which one I like better
once the PC version is out I suppose
like for the first expansion if I'm
really enjoying that well that's
actually a good question like will they
get the expansions at the same will they
get that occurred today oh I know I know
they're probably not gonna get that
exclusive content I do have a couple
yeah another place yeah he's talking
about are they gonna get expansions at
the same time yeah one I think I think
they would get the expansions at the
same time but you know that perception
and the Destiny community where you know
that Playstations the place to play
because of the exclusives do you think
people are going to choose 30 extra
frames over that exclusive content uh
yeah it's an interesting question it was
it was in a little bit of an easier
choice between Xbox and Playstation like
I understand people better for the Xbox
just because in
you play with your friends like you're
absolutely Xbox you get on the Xbox
end of story you don't really care about
an exotic because you know you play with
your friends but if you're if you are
twittering if you're a youtuber getting
access to those exotics is a big deal
right like you don't really want to see
that that content and but yeah now that
the PP seeds it boasts better specs I
don't know I feel like not look at maybe
suede no no I'm gonna have to play it on
the PC and see how it runs and like be
right in it's fantastic and I'm picking
it up on PC as well as a you can have
all the frames you want but like my raid
group is on the ps4 right and I don't to
get another one on the PC that's rust
like it is really hard to maintain two
entire different destiny to accounts
like it's like you know cactus has to
choose between do I want to play this
raid cuz like you know PC you know for
someone who's you know I'm pretty sure
you stream correct
cactus yeah yeah you you twitch so it's
it's definitely easier to twitch on a PC
than it is console it's like way easier
it's not even comparable but like then
you got that other perspective like
that's still a month of playing it on
PlayStation and you know people you know
pretty much a lot of people in the
conversation ain't gonna get this puts
people in here destiny a month and
destiny time might as well be two years
in real life time so hope you know you
put you're gonna play that for a whole
month on on console when you get to PC
your hard do I really want to start over
right now like yeah I mean PC version
does come out kind of in a good time in
the sense that comes up kind of in a
lull in the sense that des études gonna
come out you're gonna you know level up
get the exotics the raise is gonna come
out I'm sure and you're gonna have
that's all gonna happen within likely
the first month or so yes
around two months even and then October
24th rolls along it's right in the in
the point where you've kind of done the
content for dusty too if you're going
especially if you go on pretty hardcore
and then you're waiting for the December
expansion to come so it's kind of like
the perfect time to jump on to the PC
get used to that you know people gonna
I'm sure wanna see gameplay and
high-resolution stuff from that and yeah
so it kind of comes out at a decent time
that you can make this switch and then
start leveling up your character in that
low yeah it's a tough decision you're
right yeah absolutely alright it's a
tough decision like you said also from
the stand point if like you said you see
those 60 frames and it's just looking
gorgeous and the whole 4k bit it you
have to get into these topics apologize
to the chat obviously started a little
late we had a little technical
difficulties but we got them squared
away well we got some great topics for
you guys we're gonna get right into it
so obviously it's a huge destiny to
Newsweek we had a lot of information in
reference to clans stuff like that in
the Bungie update and the debut of Ice
Ice Baby the pre-order exclusive that
won't be available in game until
December 5th
for those who don't pre-order has been a
little controversy and that's these
streets about these practices so I want
to bring this to the round table and do
we feel that this the lost feel that
this is anti-consumer and I want to
start off with the Lord CAG is
themselves
how do we feel about this whole practice
and just about the whole cohort
pre-order exclusive in itself um well
it's an interesting question i don't you
know i don't love making exotics
pre-order blowing so it depends on how
you get them right like it's um if it's
just randomly in the loop table and then
it's enabled for the people who
pre-ordered the game i think that's a
good way to do it if you're just
outright giving it to people i think
that's a little lame i think that
devalues the exotic a ton like if you go
to your postmaster and you just get it
right
money brought me it really doesn't feel
like an exotic at that point you know it
just cause it's like uh your I
envisioned that you just go to a certain
NPC and basically get it it that could
be a way on how that how that works
which is again obviously not great but
of the sense of just having that period
or bonus I say don't think it's is that
bad in the sense that like if you really
entered is it's kind of weird like the
people who are kind of upset are the
people who really into destiny and it's
like y'all have already pre-ordered the
game like don't be upset come December
5th like if you're that concerned about
it just pre-order the game like you
already got a chance to play it with the
beta I think that's a little obvious Lee
that sounds I'll you know it's not
perfect in a perfect world you wouldn't
have any of this craft but you know it's
just kind of the things we're dealing
with and I much rather have a pre-order
bonus that you get in December which is
kind of reasonable whereas the
PlayStation bonuses you get you know in
2018 which is way way WAY worse by a
million miles so give me a pre-order
bonus over a console exclusive bonus any
day frankly I jump in on this what's
funny is Xbox is gonna get both of those
we might we have access to the pre-order
but guess what there's still gonna be
exclusive content as well I was actually
surprised the Xbox did get this I was
actually like oh wait I was like triple
reading the fine print Lord cactus was
like as I said are we getting it is it
respect like the terms and agreements
you got to read them all make sure you
ain't I'm pretty sure they're gonna give
it to you through a storyline you're
gonna have to build a weapon just saying
way you had to build a Gallo on that
would be yeah for some reason I feel
like it's gonna be how you got the skin
for the Gjallarhorn for the rise of iron
you're just gonna go to the postmaster
and they're good like hey look what I
found
I hope
like Lord caca says d values the gun um
work for it you know put it as something
that you have to do it with a Titan or
warlock and a hunter you know do it
something do it in a way that you work
for it you earned it
but it was available for the pre-order
guys you know just doing that that man
and I think it'll work out
I just want my swords back man I don't
even care about that gun I got look hot
I'm sorry miss the mr. freeze gun it's
kind of different than any other gun in
the game like the closest game the
closest type of gun to it is like a
fusion rifle
all right beyond that I mean this is a
steady stream so these are made from
armor long as well
Oh which is my favorite round you shout
out to her man what's the other one
again uh hockey so my favorite one
hockey is my family okay not even a
smooth there's a sweetie a serous but
like I feel like the exotic these
sorrows kind of like you know I was I
was so used to that gun by the time they
actually started making faction guns
yeah it took a hit and like you know
this is cool I've had this gun for like
ever now you just made an auto rifle
version of it or post rifle what's so
different about the gun again because
it's it's it's it's closest in kind of
the way it functions to like a fusion
rifle which kind of takes a minute to
charge up and then you shoot off a bolt
this is in terms of function it's kind
of it's a steady stream though it's like
it's like the laser like the like though
you don't have to eat it up you just
shoot it answers a little laser be not
who who thinks Bungie isn't gonna mess
this get this going up on launch and
it's gonna like it's it's gonna be like
that scene and Batman where he's just
shooting like a whole line of people and
they're freeze
listen it will be an interesting gun to
balance I'll see you want to see how
they do that but oh yeah when the
developers were talking about it like
that with the guy in the reveal video
which I was surprised that in a video
that early just announced the gun he
mentioned he's a guy this is our only
what's called a trace rifle with that
laser being a constant laser beam that
when you shoot it as you shoot it starts
to get a little bit more and more and
more recoil as kind of the balances yes
alright and even sexually he's like this
is a gun that is our only trace rifle
right now but you know it's a good that
we might see I made into a gun type
later on and I was like yes to it that
work you could get different guns like
that and have elements attached to it in
the hot conversion and all know that
stuff yeah absolutely and I think Lord
Coty's made a good point I think that
the balancing Factory obviously the
longer you hold down on the gun you know
shoot the more recoil it gets the harder
it gets to control so yeah it's pretty
calm cos I'd be excited to as well they
don't that's okay look I can sir well
you know one of the biggest things that
I do really want them to focus on
destined to like probably one of the top
things is I want them to actually make
factions you know more in debt like I
don't want them just to be a gun on why
every you know a lot of the guns to have
a place you know a place holder in
history it's like you know the last war
it has a lot lot behind it I want the
factions to be really yeah I want people
in the factions to have like a
personality like Kay obviously not Cade
but you know it's like you rock with
people for more than just what guns they
have right absolutely you know hopefully
like I said I mean according to devs and
you know they're saying it they're gonna
pack this thing with so much story are
you gonna get sick of it so hopefully
that'll be part of the you know that all
that all plan so um back to back on
topic real quick so everyone is of the
thought that this is not anti-consumer
we're where we are with that with the
original way worse practices event I
think this is oh
to be honest with you like you pre-order
a week giving you something like extra
this wasn't in the pre-order package
this is some there now it's later on so
this is pro kusuma now anti-consumer
would be whoa whee - down something that
you pre-cut what I do think that you
know is a point that it is a little
anti-consumer but at the end of the day
like there's other things that's way
more anti-consumer we need a worried
about them then a pre-order gun like
come on like you know say they would
turn around and say that that there was
three other different exotics on one for
Best Buy
law khakis you in what are your latest
videos you had mentioned that there's
also a pre-order bonus as far as a ghost
with a kill count now that is a hurt
game I don't know what's that another
listen did you break it down for me that
came out was for this UK retailer game
which is like the UK version of Game
Stop and it said very specifically the
trailer I said exclusive to game game
exclusive booth well it turns out he
does know what exclusive means it's
exclusive to everybody you notice like
people were sending these screenshots
and of course you know yeah like I did
no I just reported the information that
was out at the time but then yeah people
were selling me screenshots of like if
you go to the digital deluxe ish and I
think like on the PlayStation or on the
Xbox and you look at the pre-order
bonuses it says like kill tracker ghosts
so it just seems to be everywhere oh
gosh okay like that thing looks sweet
where you whip it out and tell somebody
kills you got someone saying that in the
comments like look there better be some
ghosts with other stuff like you take
them out and like you know stuff appears
because otherwise I'm using the kill
counter ghosts and like wow to use
another ghost why do use a normal ghost
like I hope you there's a way to reset
the kill count not like I have a
stationary where you can never reset it
because I feel like certain times you
might want that to be at zero yeah
there's a very start of the game but you
know some people yeah I guess I guess
like I'm saying for like does it count
for pvp and PVE yes yeah that you you
whip it out like you like as if you were
to take your ghost out it tells its a
little symbol like the crucible symbol
that tells all it like total crucible
kills and in the bottom okay I thought
it was over all kills PvP on campaign is
separated yeah that makes more sense
like that the reason I said that is
because like I feel like some people
would want that PvP aspect more than the
PvE and I didn't know that they
separated no yeah they do separate so it
all C's does seem sweet like it I mean
ghosts are so useless in in the sense of
like what they don't actually really do
anything they're just kind of a part of
your gear so the fact that you can like
hey I'll check out my kills or whatever
I think it's kind of cool and I hope
more ghosts have that gimmicks like that
I don't know what they would be but is
kind of a cool cool thing yeah I agree I
agree I went back to the monkeys loving
listening so whip it out right now
does it's a cool pre-order exclusive and
I'm glad to find out that everyone will
get it including digitally you know from
me as far as the whole cohort exclusive
thing I don't think it's anti-consumer I
mean it's one of those things that you
know the end of the day you know it's a
business bungees in the art of trying to
promote this game and if you're gonna
pick it up you were still gonna spending
that same money you know what luck I
said a lot of the times these people
even add like a week after you you the
game is out they still give you the
pre-order it's not like you know a lot
of the times
these pre-order bonuses is just like
after a certain amount of time I mean
there's there's still some games that I
could still get the preorder bonus
that's still on the store that came out
month and a half ago you probably find a
pre-order code like not to difficulty
yeah
now again like I said I mean I feel that
this is this again not anti-consumer I
could say if you want you're gonna pick
up the game you preorder it you get you
know setting and again even if you still
feel that Santa consume your soul up in
arms morally against doing that you can
wait until December 5th right and then
get the game yeah I mean get the exotic
normally so you know I was looking at
you know the comment section a couple of
things I thought it was an interesting
topic but um before we move on I
actually want to give it back to Lord
edit because I know he had a question
for or like åkesson reference to like
sixes I believe so so you know
especially you know I felt like this is
the perfect week that you know you could
came out here cactus because I feel like
out of everyone I know on YouTube
because I've been following your channel
for a while I would say that you know
you're right up there to the people that
you know I go to that go-to person for
that PvP aspect of destiny so absolutely
what I want to ask you is for V 466 is
what's one then why uh I mean I would
consider myself more of a PvE guy to be
honest so it's interesting to hear that
but I guess I still slaying PvP so I'll
do my best I honestly really enjoyed the
Destiny to beta for PvP like I thought
yes talk about the gunplay was smooth I
really liked how it wasn't so ability
spammy like that's dope that's the thing
I hate about you know at the end we were
coming the ended s he died like the most
infuriating thing when you know you're
pulling your pulse and a guy down admit
some Titan just jumping at you midair
you're killing them suddenly you see his
arm you know wiggle and you're like it's
over and you just see that fusion rifle
stick right on you and you're like uh as
you kill him like you kill him you got
him down you have way more gun skill but
he just presses one button that he's
stable
you can add you're done so like it took
away from a lot of gun skill and nothing
like for me I have a ton of gun skill in
games like dude when I go into
battlefield 4 I got like 70 and 10 it's
an absurd at lower sorry bout that one
when I go to call of duty I do really
well as well and it's because I have
really good gun skill I can I can gun
people down like I can see them but it's
one of the things like we're in destiny
I still did decent bite I didn't I
definitely didn't do as well and it's
because there just wasn't as much of her
Alliance like gun skill you really need
to know when to use your abilities when
to retreat when to jump around which is
definitely a cool aspect of the game I
don't want to make it sound like it
should all be gun skill but it got to
the point near the end there where it's
really almost not no reliance on gun
skill but like really limited it was all
about food it was all about you know or
lightning grenades and like or the the
guns you used with stuff like the
icebreaker where it's just like you're
in the back of the map just sitting in
the same spot my goodness going dusty -
I really enjoyed that I don't like it's
interesting I don't know 6v6 verses 44
because des études only been 44 I wish I
could have played a 6 v6 version Bessie
- I think that would be kind of
interesting to try but you know destiny
to where it feels like it's mostly gun
skill and then your abilities complement
that so it's like yes you can be a
skilled player and then the people who
like really know when to use abilities
and stuff they can just like enhance
that experience they can be good and
then knowing when to use abilities makes
you even better well I enjoy I enjoy 4
before I do I cannot just begin to
describe to you like you can act like oh
you know I'm nice and in PvP even in
destiny 1 but you know I got I got to
the point where I'm so sick and tired of
people just running at me what uh you
know shoulder charging I got tired of
people only relying on special for
everything I got tired of people slide
shotgunning me tired of titans tired of
fusion girduckis
it's like it doesn't matter if I'm nicer
with you with a park ride
than you are it doesn't matter cuz this
is a lot of times where I can outshoot
people with sniper rifles but it's very
far in between because it wasn't about
you know I agree
I completely agree it shouldn't all be
gunplay but I feel like at the end of
the day destiny one promoted more spammy
stuff than they actually did you know
there was times R it promoted complaint
like there's times when in year one or
it was all about gunplay it was all
about primary people down and then they
kept nerfing primaries like over over
again and I just got to the point where
just things weren't you know necessarily
balanced properly I'd have an auto rifle
I would shoot someone in the head like
literally perfect aim every shot to the
head and they would just get like Stu
spazzy body shots on one headshot with a
pound job and kill me before I could go
them and you're like okay this is how
this is gonna work that's that seems
fair yeah it made the PvP and I will say
this you know there's a lot of people
that would have stayed on destiny if
that PvP would have been a little bit
more balanced and and you know I'll
remember the one when I when I gave up
on Destiny's PvP and you you know you
can ask those Lords in your I really
play pvp and probably a year and a half
on destiny one is when they made that
change the trials of Osiris for you
didn't have special ammo and I felt like
you know that really encouraged people
because the grenades were annoying but
it was the snipers the shotguns
that's what annoyed me the most which is
really cool that they actually put it
now in a different slot in a power slot
to kind of uh no I have loved it and you
know I enjoy trials for the first time
in weeks
and I was like you know this is fun you
know you know you round to three you
still deal with that you know that dude
that will not shoot with you of a
primary he will literally slide shot
slide shot that you know they call them
you know the titan slider so you know do
you know the shotgun apes man you know I
enjoyed it and then like two or three
weeks later they like okay we're gonna
put that back in there look no what are
you doing and then after that I was like
I'm done with bugs I would strictly PvE
because I was a very balanced destiny
player once they did that chain
than they redone it I was like they're
listening to the people you know
complaining over what's good for the
game so I'm done hey so over all sixes
versus for everyone what what where we
where we at with this is consider how
much team shotting is now a thing in
Betsy too because of the time to kill is
so high like it's all about team
shouting yes I don't know if six is it
would you consider that sixes might be
like even worse for that so just
consider that go ahead and say this okay
I think they should bring a casual
playlist for 66 you know something
that's not really it's like you know
cactuses last video it's like you know
there's certain times where you want to
go in the crucible and you ain't trying
to play six Sinister's yeah I agree with
that but the pranic the problem and I
think that the good thing about four
before everywhere is because it ensures
bounds like the problem and kind of a
casual playlist was 66 is like you know
the reason everything's four before is
because stuff and trials versus stuff in
the I agree 66 yeah it was just so
different like it was just so different
the scope of how how their a balanced
and so if they had a casual players with
6v6 God knows people are just gonna play
nothing but that and complain about
stuff that's overpower than that but
isn't over pardon for before and just be
all of them wants being like I can't
believe you allowed this in the game is
gonna Murphy and then it's gonna be even
worse than four before so I I like the
commitment to four before
across-the-board it makes and and you
know the balance I think what people
went at them it's like look like you
know I get that you know there's people
an anchorman and then he's always hating
on it so I don't really count his
opinion so you don't forget where people
were talking sixty-six guy he's a six
week where people are talking about the
sixty-six I do and you know I to a point
I would like them to have that casual
mode to play but you know cactus made a
good point
like looking one of the biggest reason
problems we have will balancing in
destiny one was they would fix something
in you know PvE and it would carry it
over to PvP and make that bus that or
vice versa and make something completely
unreliable
PvE
so you know I feel like one of the
biggest things that really helps out in
PVE it's that double primary you know
where you can't have that spamming
shotgun and the fact that you don't have
four supers running around at all times
running around know what you saying I
get you say shout out to everybody to
chat you say it six three six was nice
though he said cuz you could play with
more homies and to fire teams together
now it's it's one fire team of four and
he's just a random pick up so outs he
has a good point in this sense in that
outside of the raid activity there's
really nothing else to do with six
people so I don't know why you can't do
patrol with six people I guess more text
I was just about to say I'm so glad you
said that and that was one of the things
that really upset me because I was
hoping when we got the information on
the new Patrol stuff that you know I
could bring my whole fireteam what's
funny is we know how to get it we know
how to finesse the system to make sure
we get more people in there but we
shouldn't have to a code to get people
into what was the one like we were
finessing a way to get into that part in
a reserve iron where you what was that
uh ready remember what it was kind of
like will you you get the deal more
items the fourth yeah you know you go in
the floors you'd be like you know find
people that are low and be like yo can
you sit my friend invites so we could do
these and then eventually he promotes
your dude there was a couple of times
where I see some really messed up stuff
we come to that I see people ask to get
their friend and then say yo I can't see
my friend invite would you promote me
then he wouldn't pick to do that sit on
the invite and then invite to a more
people I feel free I want to get lost
oven looking anything quiet almost far
as the ohm you're feeling as far as
sixes versus four I mean let's talk a
lot siren the our destiny expert for
very simple selfish reason I suck all
the more father for me to be able to
shoot is better for me like you know
there is before before my deficiencies
are glaring
you know so know
so in terms of that definitely I would
like 6v6 it's more akin to what I'm used
to with playing Halo so but again I've
played a lot of it in the beta and it
was it was cool it took some getting
used to like I said last week I would
you know when we're doing them I just
kind of run up into the control point
and try to strafe and run around and
that's a that's a halo thing that's not
a destiny thing and I learned very
quickly that's not that's not a good way
to go about it um in terms of one thing
I want to ask you guys in terms of what
they've said about rage so far have they
said that rage of old all rates are
definitely gonna be gonna be solved well
sex V okay yeah cuz I just was wondering
since they they were focusing on on
before before if again like it was six
people running down and I coli man I'm
still a little bit terrified of a RAID
with Kabbalah I'm sorry it might not be
the cabal might not be the command
saying yeah kegs did we want to debut on
the ILP inside information just just
information okay documenting man watch
it watch it be the tech old OSI no it's
not gonna it's not gonna be any case it
might be the vex again to be honest okay
I would yeah that would make sense like
you okay with that I would like I guess
a lot of people would be mad about that
let me roll here the internet would cry
about that why yeah I am who knows I
think that there's a huge possibility
that we finish off the cabal in the
story like that seems like where else
would the story go right I feel like the
last story mission is you defeating Gul
I like it kind of would be a pretty lame
ending if you didn't and it was like oh
do the raid we know a lot of people
don't do the raid so I feel like Bungie
wouldn't do that so there's a good
chance that the raid is just something
completely separate they're like hey the
the cabal were thinking around
[Music]
unnecessary
to go and investigate another big vex
rape or you during the gameplay though
that one little tiny thing of gameplay
that we've seen of the people running to
six people running down the stairwell it
looks like it's on Nessus and also at
the very top there's one of those like
pyramid doors which is exactly akin to
well first of all a door that you can
see unnecessarily near that it was one
of like things you could find if you
went off the beaten path we're in the
beta when you did that but also it's the
exact same like pyramid style vex door
that you find in the vault of glass
several times so I mean we've seen very
little evidence but the few evidence the
like tiny evidence the one clip we have
seen is not necessarily pointing to
cabal although the Cabal definitely have
a presence on necess if you're expecting
a raid to reach you know kill Gul as the
final raid boss and to retake the last
city I would stop expecting that it
makes way more sense as a story mission
and as a raid Lucca and you know I know
a lot of people would probably say about
orc source was a difference that was it
was different it was exceptions there
you know they explained it you know you
can't kill yeah yes so you know that
definitely and you know it would make
sense like I would like for that to
happen and it turns out that like you
know the vex were controlled like you
know they were manipulating the Cabal
into attacking the town or so yeah
that's you're like because he was sort
of weird endgame I don't even know it's
boring where do you go get the machine
to drain the light that's something you
have to and then we also know -
obviously he's eased to let the lead of
that red Legion but obviously there's
still the Queen and there's still a
whole bunch of the hierarchy with that
as well so it seems like sort of like
splinter faction of the Cabal like
pretty much like all army is just like
some jerks there like showed up
running is you know like he went on and
on about like you know your your race
don't deserve this and I was like well
if you want to say you're you know
you're the person that can defeat them
like you had to drain the light to beat
them like like though I'm like don't
puff your chest out would you taking
their cards away from you look tacky I
want to get lucky I didn't get a chance
to comment on all sixes versus four so
looking if you still there yeah okay I
want to get you get you in on that your
feedback well what I would like bunchy
to do the introduces our casual Fridays
casual Fridays with consisted of 6v6 you
know just a Friday for those casual guys
you know trying to unwind for a weekend
get your friends in get a little day
party they're going good and it's over
on Saturday the 4v4 I thought it was
fantastic and an essence status when I
play PvP I sucked I'm not gonna I mean I
got into it it was all about sticky
bombs and supers and was like oh god and
then somebody got a chance to sleep you
from across the board while all the guys
did a super bar thank you and it was
just like ah the hell with this I'm
gonna go play prisoner elders yeah yeah
control the narrative in the prison of
elders and I run with my team when we
get it done there's there's quite there
isn't really quite the experience that
you have in any other games when you
hear that hammer you hear that super
initiation that someone does inactivated
they see or you walk around a quarter to
a Blade Dancer run we would do the raids
every day you we will run the raids ten
times a day because we were able to be
in there with our friends you know six
people let's get it done
we was having such a good time so casual
Friday is a really work if you're gonna
do it iron band I don't know about the
iron banner guys I know that I really
wrap it with it
so you might like we 166 or you know the
4v4 I was coming in at the top of the
leaderboard on some of our matches and
four before because like look hacker
said it was gunplay baby it was all
about how good you were with your gun a
few ran with
me y'all was able to take down a team of
two and you know shields get up you
might throw a grenade you know but you
when you saw that you had a grenade you
had to really think should I throw this
right now I should wait more perfect
opportunity yes so it was more strategy
involved with Holly fantastic this time
and I really like you said when the beta
left I was devoid but it was a void and
you made good points looking because
they know shots of people don't know in
the chat like Lord King does not even
touch PvP you like Iron Man we have we'd
have to drag Lord no now when it comes
to a raid strikes nightfall he got you
you know but it was one of those things
we were just like you know I would try
to get him and he just you know he
wouldn't do it so when we started in the
destiny to beta and I'm like I see Lord
kid get to it you know at the primary
gunplay he's doing his thing he's on the
top of the board doing nice to the
abilities the option to you know to do
something extra you know it from a
balanced standpoint for as I feel is
perfect I have to admit you know it does
feel good from what I played my only
concern with if sixes are not there
because I eat three I got a chance speak
to Lord earth McGuirk and III kind of
pressed them Lord caucus I said look I
understand from a balanced and point you
guys got knocked it out the park you
know all I'm saying is like it's gonna
feel kind of weird when Ironman rolls
around and there's no six so what he
said to me in true Bungie marketing
speak has that he goes well we have
that's what we have to announce at this
time you know you just basically said
force or will be initially launched you
know so he didn't rule out the
possibility you know why they wouldn't
do like party modes if everyone wants 61
that they could have like infection
where it's 12 person infect it like
infection like in Halo or like a gun
game style game we get like a red
exotic every kill or they could make
really fun like party game modes in
destiny and but I mean and there's
something that may introduce in the
future but also it detracts from I mean
certainly now they're giving off the
vibe of like we were taking ourselves
super seriously in PvP which you don't
want to be doing that and be like or you
can play WIC wackety wild gun game you
know it doesn't really make sense so
that's something they may announce in
the future I hope they do because I you
know it's nice to take a little bit
break a break from the sweat fest but
absolutely and absolutely yes are we all
excited to you know when it came down to
it as much as I hate to say this that
Bungie went back to their roots they're
like you know we had probably one of the
most competitive first-person shooters
and we're gonna go back to that 4v4
style the halo and all and also let's
let's not even we have to acknowledge
the their presence and wanting to get
more involved with eSports and you're
one of the things shout to look
haibach's witty chat is also one of the
things that they had to address was that
like you know the one-hit-kill stickies
all stuff Lord King mentioned you know
all that kind of you know spam like half
the stuff would be banned if they went
into official use they're like well you
can use three guns we'll know like when
they did the Guardian con PvP tournament
literally every single person was using
a palindrome or an is Luna by the end of
it like like one pulse rifle and then
one guy was using what's his name tier
one riot was using a burning eye and
actually got like a 15 kill streak but
it's so good for him but everyone else
was just doing the same to guns and you
know you know Lou babies game that's
happening something's wrong something's
wrong exactly so that's the good thing
about fours and balanced but uh if
everyone's got off their topic we're
gonna move on to the next segment and I
got Oh Lord sovereign up and I you want
to talk about what's going on in the
world of pop G
battlegrounds what's going on what's up
yeah so in the past week or so they've
been ahead two to sort of kerfuffles in
the world of what take these on one at a
time
so the first one is the announcement
that um plenum unknown made that they
were gonna be adding they were gonna be
adding loot crate's to the game in this
next update paid loot crate so basically
the crates were free and you would have
to pay for keys to open the crates um
and obviously obviously the internet the
internet being the internet kind of
jumped at it basically attacking the
fact that uh he made it clear that again
they don't want to make this game that
the people that love this game the
people are around this game don't want
it to be like into something like a team
fortress or other games that have gotten
even counter-strike games that have
gotten into the into the habit of
charging for content that many people
believe should be free right now in this
day and age in trying to release a game
on PC and other consoles now um it is
and for a game that they were selling
maybe for $30 so it is it is a paid game
so you should expect the pay model to
continue throughout the lifetime of the
game so paying for extra stuff
regardless of what it is content would
have it just uh just in terms of like
cosmetic stuff it's something you should
expect to be paying for um and so the
internet at large is saying no we don't
want this way I don't know made it made
it um made it clear that two of the
crates that were being released oh that
one of the crates in particular was
everything that that was collected from
that was going towards um charity in
addition to setting up a fund for a
Gamescom tournament so it's for
basically whoever wins the tournament at
Gamescom and all of these think what
this does is promote
the game and give the game a broader
audience honestly I feel that it's it's
a ridiculous thing for people who buy
and enjoy this game and at this point
have gotten hundreds of hours of
enjoyment out of this game to be mad
about something that's a cosmetic that
they don't have to pick up and be what
continue is gonna add to how the game
improves over time and and his ability
to maintain the game over time I mean I
think people have to educate themselves
more about what these type of additions
to the game allow the game to be in the
future and allow them to support it you
know five ten years down the line let me
ask you a question before we bring it to
the rest of round table because I'm
still getting my information on this
actual topic so what is it so right is
these are like crates that drop with
cosmetic items what what exists Trading
is going on in this update
they have cosmetics that are based on
the movie battle royal okay this kind of
which is kind of the inspiration for
this game so a lot of these costumes
right so the thing is that each crate
apparently has only a piece of a costume
so it's not like you're getting an
entire wardrobe in one crate right also
you gotta okay you got to pay that -
right hopefully you get the arms and
okay but the argument against it is well
you don't have to get this stuff this is
all stuff that if you want you can
invest the time in the money into it and
you know again but but the the argument
some people make is like no it shouldn't
be that way if we pay X amount of money
for the game everything that comes down
the pipeline should be free the game's
calls way too much the main especially
this type of game it costs way too much
to maintain didn't for them to just give
you everything and again even the
argument people are making is well you
know if this is gonna be the case moving
forward that you better make sure you a
stabilize the game be make sure that
everything runs smoothly see any any
under the hood quality of life
enhancements come or come faster
and without issue so they're like it's
like they're holding the game to ransom
in that regard like whoa um what will
allow this if you do it you know X Y Z
and it's like country's like really like
we need to understand the dynamics of
this and how difficult it is to maintain
the game that especially now that has
has blown up the way it has it you need
you need money coming in need money know
what King I'm curious of your subject
matter individual super beta testing you
my friends are super beta testers for
free but you are paying us to beta test
this broken game we will fix stuff as we
go and we will ask for your input for
free but you will pay for this stuff
that we're gonna implement in the game
that you already paid for the founders
Edition um I found this Edition thing
I'm gonna talk about that later in my
segment I hate that word I hate it I
hate the word because it gives you a
sense of entitlement these kids feel
entitled now by saying that's deal I'm
down with this I'm with y'all we put in
this game together we're not doing
anything you're playing the game they're
telling you that this content is gonna
be there if you choose to purchase set
content purchase set content if you do
not choose to purchase that content and
continue to play the game that you've
been beta testing forever then continue
to do so but these guys are buying a key
right because I remember the thing
before that had me completely outrages
you pay $10 for this crate and anybody
could get it they've found a workaround
pocket you get to a crate and you open
it
here's where they messed up again these
guys think they gotta be freaking idiots
or masterminds one of the two but the
line is very freakin blurry you get out
of this crate a random item
now yes a random cosmetic item a piece
of clothing it could be a hat a shirt
pair boots or pants but it's random so
you paid 250 for this key you ran out
there you got yourself a pair of boots
you said man all I need is some pants
and a shirt and a hat I'm good money you
run back out there you get a pair poops
[Laughter]
how frustrating that must be for the
individual who only has $10 in his pay
pal who really wants to get an outfit to
show off to his friends when he kills
you and he poses it on YouTube but he
can't because he just got the boots
$3 left and it's dead on PayPal I'm
sorry
I don't subscribe to the model of the
stuff that they're doing and I know this
is only in empowering more developers to
do the same crap
I don't worry I wouldn't jump in get
lucky so this because look hack is if
refresh my memory does not sound eerily
similar the festival lost stuff ish when
when it was like far as like you pay and
you get like a those random cosmetic
items or something like that oh it was
one of those things where even maybe the
dawning also had something like that
where you could pay and you get random
chances at the you know like a uniform
set something to that effect look it all
sounds nice and peachy when it's caught
yes cuz when they gonna lead off to pay
all that stuff but I understand why
people would be wary I mean literally
look at black ops 3 start out cosmetic
only oh guys it's just cosmetics just
gonna sting Wham
suddenly weapon right introduced full
weapons and now it is it's brutal it's a
super low chances they get crypto keys
like almost never it's just brutal RNG
system
so you understand why people are like
just wary of that cuz a lot of game
companies they're doing that they start
out cosmetic only to get people used to
the idea into the can then and then
suddenly you know you're getting hey you
know maybe you'll get one of the items
will be a bandolier item or a vest that
that can hold a little bit more ammo in
pubsey when you get a certain gun and
then suddenly wait a minute that's a
little bit pay to win but they ease in
there right they don't just no they
don't just you know show out the door
hey losers we're doing paid away today
today today to learn cosmetics tomorrow
$2 for an airstrike like look at like a
destiny start out cosmetic only then
suddenly have those uh suddenly it's
like oh hey you can get a booster where
you get double exp when grinding
Vanguard our crucible or whatever and
it's like wait a minute
ah that's not cosmetic that's I mean
I've maintained and it's surprising how
everyone was just so okay with it that
was mean you would have first on the
frontline law caucus I got to give you
that you were the first one I was
undeniably like in a loop based game the
fact that you get double experiencing at
loot twice as often and good loot like
you know you get your LD ours of the
time and stuff faster and like that was
new and it didn't ruin the game or
anything I'm not arguing that but it was
a little itch it was a little douchey to
Chet he started trouble
he said let's plan out the elephant the
room that activision does the bulk of
this BS and it should police fish yeah
yeah he's actually been like in for
battlefield EA skeptic cosmetic only and
for titanfall to all the DLC is free so
he is actually being pretty good with
them how days turn their entire image
around and like yeah there's the one
that's really pushing this but you know
what it didn't know yes it makes so much
money it's exhausting people like you
can [ __ ] about all you want but I mean
like people are bitching as they're by
as they're in the mid purchase of more
Cod points so it's like though like the
fact that they can still update black
ops 3 with new weapons like they added
the an-94 like last month and they're
still updating this really old Call of
Duty game that like normally they would
just abandon this thing but they're
still updating it because the
microtransactions makes so much money
they Bungie made more money with the
rise of iron than they did with the
initial launch of the dent dang game so
it's like it's it's really really like
why would you not do that you know if
your activision why would you stop doing
that you're losing so much in some so
fact people need to realize that like
their dates a business they can [ __ ]
but if you're still buying this stuff
it's still gonna keep going
thank you and I'm glad you made that
point look that gues because shout out
to be money to check he's lit right now
paying at the nonsense will lose but we
don't want to game him but will always
continue as long as people paying and I
get at the end of the day this is a
business and as much as people [ __ ] and
complain and go on they're still doing
it you have to vote with your wallet
right and you'll say no with your wallet
that you're not gonna support those
practices but the problem is we go into
a game like pub G and guess what you see
people running around with those out
battle royal outfits you load up a game
like this Lee and what did you see
everybody I saw it you know shout out
that you know my god Neil forgot a
declare but as soon as day one he had
like all the taken armor when it first
debut the thing is though also know it's
not purely negative cuz it ended a look
they get a massive revenue from yes
microtransactions as we've said it's not
all going to you know cosmos summer
house that's just not it's going to the
company and you know yeah some is going
in the pockets of some upper level
employees I'm sure but at the end of the
day that money a lot of it is used
to make more more and more content um
you know the reason they're able to put
on a big event like the age of triumph
and even the dawning was relatively late
you know it was decent the strikes
scoring and all that stuff and that's
all good news and the eople update was
fantastic those are all pretty decent
content additions like I'm sure all of
you guys were like pretty happy at the
state of the game with the age of
triumph you know like the raids a week
the weekly raids featured raise the
armor look fantastic there's a bunch of
goods good stuff implemented and the
reason they're able to afford to put
that much effort and hire you know
you're hiring artists to do the the
armor just and then you have to hire
people to make them you have to spend a
lot of money to get that much content in
the game all for free and the reason
they're able to do that is because of
microtransactions so it is you know it's
very negative in a lot of aspects but
also at the end of the day it's positive
in the sense that it can result as long
as they're investing the money properly
in more content last point before I pass
this alone attic totally I definitely do
at that last point and also I also agree
with in this standpoint that yes
sometimes some of these practices can be
a little slimy as far as the oranjee
aspect of it but at the same time I'm a
firm believer like it's my favorite game
I want to support it I don't want it to
go away because I've been around a lot
and Lord King can attest it is most
often gonna test with oh geez here that
you know we've seen Studios come and go
you know games that we love don't get a
sequel you know things that are nature
so this is kind of the thing that it's
like a necessary evil because sometimes
you know you support them like you said
Lord cactus like that that can go back
into the game for continual support you
know me so I don't believe that there's
always this evil CEO with his feet up
with that collection box of your money
like someone is to make a skit about
that and put it on YouTube just say
absolutely you know so I definitely
definitely think you know that it can go
back into a game and continue to support
the life of the game and get more
content well real quick before I pass it
to you I know Howard I have is in the
chat he said he got a question for
khakis so
wait on that but while we're waiting on
that we'll give it to Lord addict
I want his feedback as far as the pub G
microtransaction stuff that's coming up
I mean when it comes into the whole
thing you know do I think it's right
it's definitely it I wouldn't say they
don't have the right to do it it is
their game I mean they they could charge
that $100 for their game if they want to
but the thing when it comes to it is if
they want to have you know a lasting
game because first off you know the PC
cart is not like the the console
community they're not like you know as
much as you know mean the PC crowd goes
at it a lot on my couch at you know they
do stand up for you know their itthere
ecosystem and you know that's the reason
Microsoft went over there to there to
the Windows 10 was like yo we can't
charge money for this like they will not
have it there's a reason that stuff like
that is done in the PC community only
it's like look like you know you might
get away with that on the console is it
to a point they won't even get away with
that on the consoles but let's be real
here like sooner or later that PC
community will turn on you the moment
anything is made that is a little bit
better or even on the same par as pub
they will turn on that game so you know
if they don't want to look out for the
longevity of their game like who am I to
tell them not to do it yeah and um
before we move on to the next one I know
that I haven't even you missed the
Destiny section so he had a question for
lo cactus you just said the dink galls
armor was made in the lines at e3 what
people were thinking it was vex
technology that is a good point I didn't
think about that
yeah like is white like armor
the white paper suit would keep it
doesn't like looks super vex II don't
like who knows right like I do think
that machine that [ __ ] in their lights
vex either there's definitely like an
interesting relationship with like all
the other enemy factions right and it's
like are they working together are they
stealing from each other or are they
doing alright hate each other or like
what what's going on there I think
there's some interesting stuff I have no
idea about the armor
thank God thanks for the question now to
have another chat he was waiting all day
for you okay but uh yeah I want to get
back to solve real quick with the pub
gee there's a part two to this right law
sovereign we talked about that aspect so
now what's the part two of what's going
on with published Ian on certain
platform this is the B side - this is
right yeah they announced that they had
the game up and running on a prototype
x1x not final not final Hardware yet
which is a little surprising but um it's
still a prototype um basically if they
had it running on a hundred man servers
and the game was running at somewhere
between 30 to 40 frames per second 3045
there yeah so it's somewhere in that
range
so obviously the internet being the
Internet jumped at it and and people
started talking about well the Xbox one
X this is what its gonna be able to do
that said its CPU bound all sort of
valid points kind of encased in a lot of
you know fanboy arguments and stuff like
that so basically um these are the facts
the PC game is is very CPU bound and
even at this point high-end graphics
card again and again the game is still
an early access so even at this point
high-end graphics cards sometimes have
trouble keeping steady frame rates you
know at high frame rates so the belief
now is the talk now is okay the x1x
can't do it it's gonna run at thirty
because it's it's kind of programming to
the least common denominator um what we
know about who's developing the console
version it's a five man team coming out
of Spain um it hasn't been indicated
whether the console version is being
built in the same fashion as a PC
version so we don't necessarily know
that it's it's CPU bound again um
considering that it's a five man team
maybe they don't have the resources to
be able to build it again from the
ground up and kind of offset some of
that um some of that load that CPU has
on
on the on the PC offset it differently
on a console maybe they don't have the
resources to be able to do that so just
assuming that it's the same then the
assumption can be made that yet the
games gonna be running at 30 frames per
second on consoles across the board and
again there was there was there was
arguments over that because it's like
okay here we go again
another indicator that the x1x isn't as
powerful as they claim as they claim
that it is and the truth of the matter
is that we've seen this particularly in
these in these living games in these
games that require especially for Xbox
they require the player base to be
consistent across all versions of the
platform so now when Xbox are talking
about three platforms are talking about
vanilla Xbox X 1 X s and running X
coming up we have to go to the most
common denominator as well sometimes
right exactly so you're probably looking
at a game is gonna be running 30 frames
per second on on console just to keep
those player bases together they're not
gonna want to separate those play bases
unless they make some sort of
announcement about separating servers
and allowing people to create their own
servers for X 1 X and allowing people to
play that way and giving that giving
those options um in game I don't see it
being anything more than that
so again and and again the internet may
be unjust may be justly may be unjustly
junk that bit junk that you know being
able to say look once again and
pigeon-holed themselves with this true
4k and touting all of this they put
themselves in a position where they have
to make a concession to achieve frame
rates or achieve resolution what every
time something has to be conceded they
put themselves under the microscope
under the microscope and allow
themselves to be scrutinized because of
this narrative that they chose to that
they chose the 4k narrative which is
everything okay that gotcha
so this is finish up so that's that's
basically the essence of it you begin to
net going to work on on basically uh
something that at this point it's still
speculation exactly got you any
want to jump in on this real quick going
real quick it's not even gonna take too
long and very precision like he said
five people making the gang rape in the
game together five people through the
game on the Xbox no optimization nothing
it was running from 30 frames per second
to 45 frames per second that's fantastic
that sounds great was it native 4k was
it regular 4k was a checkerboard 4k what
the hell it was we don't know but what
we do know is this that like Lord
sovereign said is there going to cater
to the least common denominator which is
vanilla xbox alright so now that we know
this we can honestly say that we believe
that it's gonna be a lakh 30 frames per
second
why for parity across the board so when
I play you you don't feel slighted no
one feels slighted it just run at a
higher resolution and a whole lot more
smoother and we won't get any dips in a
rock-solid 30 frames per second I
believe the game is gonna be that I
didn't expect it to be anything else
other than that
with this excuse me I'm a reader Excel I
don't know I don't play this on PC so I
don't really know if like 60 frames is
like like you know a deal breaker like I
don't I haven't played it at 60 frames
so I can't really you know give you an
opinion on whether or not like 30 to 40
is gonna make the game you know not
played like it should uh
I can't unless it's a C say I did not
tell you yesterday we were talking about
this topic I was like was like cactus
was probably gonna like that topic I'm
here he plays these are PC master-race
and you're not running 60 like your your
console scrub your not like it's 60
frames per second or get out like I
don't I never ever went out and said
that you know framerate I'm actually to
be honest I've always said I don't know
why constants are pushing for cable we
don't hit 60 sorry I agree like you know
I felt like I'm telling you like you
know this might be a little bit off
topic but I feel like you know
resolution this generation is ruined the
entire console progression to the future
light you know people are worries more
about if you know four K's on the screen
and not how the gameplay itself feels I
got you I got you look at cuz you were
talking at us
yeah here we go that no dude that's just
a fact like if you're the PC if the PC
community sees that
yeah consoles can only reach 30 they're
gonna be like well that's not like
getting to 60 or above frame rates is a
big deal for PC players like that isn't
a big deal and that's all I was saying
it is very important to them absolutely
what you say now in reference to your
opinion on this whole play unknown
battlegrounds oh well the Xbox one X
specifically what I you guys said it all
it's like yeah you know they came out
swinging it looked good in their press
conference when they announced it but
it's like ya can't even run strong or
again it's they're they're limiting it
on purpose because you don't want 60 on
the Xbox one X and 3 on the
which one it's just it's not even then
it's complicated I'm sure Xbox at the
end of the day though is just happy to
get pub G and it's gonna sell if it's 30
or 60 it's all the console grabs I mean
it's a huge exclusive and I'ma jump in
real quick - yeah I mean it's one of
those things where you you know this
narrative of a 4k can kind of you know
kind of bite them and you know shout out
the lot about - in the chat you know I
think I agree with him I think native
1080p 60 frames should be standard not
4k you know for case should be an option
and the other thing it to the point I've
been hearing you guys talk about the
whole um parity between lowest common
dynamic lowest common denominator being
the Xbox one the og one you know versus
DX and Mike Ibarra actually came out and
made a statement that they would not
force parity which I thought was
interesting this was during a whole
destiny - debacle no one knew was gonna
be 30 frames per second on console at
that time and um basically they threw it
back to the developer saying that
developers have the ability to make
those changes but whatever the Mac
setting could be on the Xbox one next
that they would match it so I thought
that was interesting they kind of got in
front of that but um
yeah it would be kind of weird to
segment the community also right you
know you'd have let's just say let's
just say hypothetically pubsey could hit
60 frames per second you know is that
group going to be in a separate group of
Azure cloud services you know Xbox 1s
guys who can just do 30 frames per
second you know so um it's interesting
it's interesting I think it's one of
those things that um you know they kind
of put themselves in a position by
pushing a narrative constantly a 4k 4k
and a lot of this stuff you know as far
as frames per second seems to be
cpu-bound you know and as we know the
Xbox one acts CPU you know right now
it's kind of like a hyped up version you
know of the initial one it's not like a
lot yeah it's not rising and and what
I'm seeing is unfortunately sometimes
this could this might be I hope I'm
wrong it might be the Achilles heel as
far as why we're not seeing a lot of 60
frames per second 4k titles on on the
Xbox one x one that's what I got on it
but um I'm actually gonna move on and
Lord King or Europe next to the round
table as far as a fortnight again that
drought you Fergus so um I was watching
YouTube the other day probably like a
week ago and they were like you know
people were playing for tonight and then
I saw my twitter feed somebody was like
oh for tonight is incredible I'm like oh
my god that's the game I wanted to play
Wow it's out
oh man ain't even say anything he just
dropped so I ran into the store
click-click so I'm looking at the
bundles and the bundles is like Lotus
and is like 49 and then hyacinth is $149
opposition founders Edition founders
Edition so I said okay let me see the
game description well I'm getting for
149 being a premium gamer let me know
what I'm gonna get baby no I'm looking
that's a preview program my nose went up
like smell something fishy here in the
description says nothing of what you get
for 149 if you mean to tell me if I
purchased this game at 49.95 and I
purchased the game at 149 85
I'm getting the same level of content
well yes sir the color of your founders
pack is different what does the color
get me sir get your absolutely nothing
gives you a chance to play on beta that
we threw in the preview program now I
went back to watch more video on YouTube
I said this is actually I'm worse than
the preview program yes sir yes sir yes
sir I'm watching guys like the game is
utterly broken but its plays beautifully
at some points with it's better what do
you mean a tell me I'm gonna pay for
this and it's broken
yes yes you are but here's the kicker
sir
cheering the game is absolutely released
it's gonna be free-to-play yes that's
the key wait wait wait so you mean to
tell me I'm paying you now to play a
broken game in your preview program that
next year's gonna be released to the
masses for free
yes sir free to play in 2018 that is
Widow straight face I want you to jump
in this please lock a kiss because jump
in and say that makes no sense and then
jump back out completely living in the
fact that they told you to pay for to
play this broken game which is going to
be for free later I don't get it and I
gotta jump in this is one of those
things I couldn't but when you told me
about this [ __ ] I might please gotta
be exaggerating
he's just hating on freedom there's no
way all right
I've literally pulled up right now I
have my xbox pulled up and I'm looking
at fortnight the hundred and $49 Xbox
logo cry we're currently in early access
aka PT program free to play in 2018 the
limited edition founders plaque include
the only thing that I'm seeing that
different from the other ones it's
basically two extra standard editions
for friends that's all they pretty much
dudes like you know what we have a proof
I think they do give you a little bit of
things but they're like you know these
things in it you know we should do work
if you buy a big package you know the
stuff they usually give you big statues
for and stuff no we're gonna do we're
gonna give you three copies of the games
it's gonna be free to play next year
nobody checked but it's like the thing
that also blew my mind with this was
that I've never seen a game say by the
way when you purchase this deluxe
edition
you're gonna we gonna give you two
copies of the standard edition for
friends so am i buying multiple copies
for my friends I do yeah
I do feel like some some games should
take that that pool and like you know
maybe for a little extra than your
standard like you know a hundred dollars
you get two copies of the game and you
know they'll take a little bit dip but I
feel like they'll get more engagement in
some of these games like titanfall I do
feel like some games could encourage
that kind of adoption but this game is a
free to play in a year is ridiculous
this is what I'm saying you you you're
paying to have your friends play with
you you want a free game see if it
wasn't a free to play game I can
understand this like you know like that
is a pretty good incentive like you know
you pay a little bit extra and you know
for the dude that literally was like no
I don't care fortnight is trashed
you like here you go because a lot of
people ain't get a nice free game
it's so good so I can understand that
perspective but the fact that you're
charging and I don't even think this is
technically a preview program game is it
under the the action is it under the
annual program really I'm looking at it
right now currently in early access I'm
in right next to it
but free to play in 2018 I just don't we
I just don't understand like I've what
it is is you know it's gamers in general
we have problems waiting for stuff I
mean it's if we were just saying that
you know a couple a couple minutes ago
that none of us are waiting for destiny
and that you know a lot of people that's
really interested in they're not waiting
six months to a year to play desperately
wanting to play this game you you guys
always hear me talk about optics and and
how important it is and the optics
behind this is so so bad well the number
of reasons I think to me
most egregious things about this is
specifically this this game was
announced in 2011 by every gay this is
cliffy B announced this game woof I do
want to point out that your Lord
anchorman says I waited five years for
four night I could wait another six
months exactly know you've waited you've
waited six year damn you seven years
before it was and Ferno has a good
pointed check he was like let's just say
it was twenty at launch then you get
people excited
you don't say he said you want to play
40 for early access but how did it's
screaming we don't have money we need
money to finish the game and what makes
it again we'll make some more greed this
to me is like you've been working on
this game for seven years and it's not
like you were this is epic games that
made it at this point
epic had gone solo had had gone
independent but they had money they
didn't have money so you know somewhere
along the narrative of this game it was
either scrapped and started again
because if you remember it was announced
and then it disappeared off the face of
the planet and came back looking
somewhat different than it did when it
was initially in the house it just it
screams we don't have the money to
finish the game here pay for your
friends to play this game looks good it
does it looks amazing it looks fun but
like you know it's what we were talking
about you know the whole promoting you
know cosmetic items you know the
developer / publisher inching their way
into their community to see what can we
get away with and you know and that's
not necessarily what they can get away
with on their community like if you see
this developer do this and they're like
yo like they literally just sold a game
that's free-to-play you get next year
let's do that it's like you know it's
bad for the industry going forward yes
noted back the Lord Kings point real
quick um with as far as preview program
outlaw khakis are you familiar with the
Xbox preview program in early access in
this whole because there's been a little
controversy going on about that are you
familiar with the program itself a
little bit yeah don't go now lord King
fundamentally has an issue with the
looking what what's your nose with
preview program because this basically
where this is kind of your foundation is
correct yes my problem with the preview
program is they're charging people to
play these broken games and they're
asking for feedback and you're glorified
beta tester that they pay people to do
this
they actually have research and
development teams that I actually do
this they actually go out and hire
people and test for bugs and do all this
great stuff that we are now paying for
they found a lane to put these
individuals in and they said well listen
you know when you pay for this game now
um on launch of the game you get you're
gonna have it for free
alright that sounds good but then these
guys go around and charge the game at
$30 now and then when the game releases
charges it to the masses for $60 um
again I'm fundamentally against gouging
the community and treating these people
that are eager to play your game as
sheep and cattle and this is exactly
what they're turning out to be they're
handing over money to play a broken game
to get feedback on that these guys is
gonna make millions of dollars off of at
least at the very least when the game is
released your refunded back your 30
bucks because the game made it to market
right they're not let me let me ask you
just question it which has always been
in the counterpoint that I hear for
people who are fans at the preview
program that they say you know if they
put the commitment early just say for
you know let's say for example and she
used it classic example which is Ark
shout out the Lord is II you know he's a
big art guy you know in that they paid
the $30 and you know with it with an
early commitment to the project right
and
now that it's kind of coming to fruition
and it's a retail price of what $60 they
were rewarded by paying you know the $30
early and getting it at a cheaper price
even that doesn't sway you Lord King at
all as an incentive to back a game
abacus to do that may not have the
resources like a triple-a studio so it's
not at all because the the words that
you use were entitlement words that I
thought I thought Lord Izzy was a
developer the way he was talking about
again in a sense of entitlement factor I
was definitely ground up though the
suggestions that I put in help cultivate
the game that you're getting now so now
the entitlement fact there is there with
no compensation for said gamer mm-hmm
you know he worked he actually put the
working lord dizzy actually puts in
hundreds of hours in this game so you
don't think his data is worth that's
mostly but his argument to you would be
it's worth because now that the game has
reached full release it will be $60 and
he only paid $30 and now he has the game
that's what the general for the DLC that
he paid for
well I can't defend that digging your
pockets to have you work for free and I
see like me you program as a farming
system for broken games to get it to
market and to give research and
development pay for by the Sheep to push
the game to market the Chad is a granule
order friendo saying that you know you
have a point Quality Assurance positions
on pay 40,000 contesting that it is not
part-time too late for $30 to play
devil's advocate you wouldn't have as
many games or the scope of games without
these kind of programs because there's
no way some developer out of no or some
tiny developer could make a game as big
as Ark there's no way if they were doing
it the traditional route that was the
route only a few years ago where they
Quality Assurance people the fact that
the reason we're getting these like
relatively indie games that are pretty
big in scope and even like comparable to
triple A's is because they can fund the
development through early access so
that's the muslim' for it you're getting
like way more games than you otherwise
would and and bigger games than you
otherwise would because these smaller
developers are able to fund their own
games development with early access
without it you're only indie games would
would be you know super meatboy style
games like those like your opinion of it
is instead of hiring pay contractors
hired unpaid laborers to build a house
this is exactly what the basics is of it
is because these are unskilled laborers
who are paying to play this broken game
or pose for them to go out and go and
hire the resource and develop and I know
the money is not there and what you're
saying is that this is tomorrow no your
point of they should go and hire people
but my point is yeah I think they don't
have money it can't afford it so it's
exactly like so the either the game
wouldn't be able to exist I'm saying
that's my point
lark would not be able to exist
potentially if they tried to do with the
traditional route so yeah I agree with
you that a lot of times it's unfortunate
you have these developers that do a lot
of these douchey practices like art with
charges you see and then Jackie at least
yeah yeah they're used definitely wrong
ways you can do it there's been a couple
of cases where it has been the right way
and you're at the end of the day you
know the consumer it's up to you you
know you don't date they'd say on the
Box this is early access this is gonna
be buggy and so if you go in there and
you're like oh my gosh the early access
game I bought is buggy messages that
said it was going to be buggy on the way
in this is your own damn fault
no it's not
you know I'm definitely I've always been
the you know for the preview program
regardless you know what developers
misused the program and you know the art
thing is I think that's one of the very
few scenarios that's actually been used
besides the sport not issue that the
preview program helps the industry more
than it hurts it and the day you just
get more games from it yeah the state
you've only way to say you vote with
your wallet yeah but continue like I'm
sorry I mean look at games like Ark you
know huge following a very passion
falling you know one of the I've always
said destiny has has that hardcore
following that very few games have an
arc is one of those games that has that
passionate following people you know
people that spend thousands of hours on
this individual games you know that
wouldn't have been around so you know
that would not have been there without
previa day have done it a little bit
differently yeah they should have worked
on the same ability of the game but you
know I feel like for the most part
they're like you know they were going
off with the feedback one they're like
you know we want different maps and it's
like you know if you want us to you know
do different maps we're gonna have to
charge wouldn't you know it he could
have been a little bit different if they
wait till after the game was launched
before they did that you know that
subjective some people would you know we
want scorch we didn't want though you
know we wanted you to work on newer
content like that so you know that's
subjective but you know look how many
gangs we've gotten from the preview
program you know sheltered even even you
know plug the game we were just talking
about that's in preview on PC is it not
yeah this is true is selfish to be
honest with you my whole aspect behind
the preview program is based behind a
bet so polished before my question for
you real quick if you could get a heart
a head start on destiny to by paying $30
now in exchange for feedback you said
don't tell me that my bad Lord King we
can go fast
you know what what he's saying is
absolutely true you know and listen I
will pay the whole 60 you can take my
money and lie to you but then again it
boils down to you pay with your wallet
for what you want to play if you can get
to play something early access like I
said I really wanted to play for at
night they really turn me away when they
said no if they told me that the game
was coming on next year and it'll be a
regular $60 price yeah I paid a touch to
a game I would be part of this pre based
in freedom I agree I feel like the free
to play is a different like that's very
what it's like when it comes to 3G
programs that doesn't happen a lot like
scenarios like that almost never happen
where it goes from paying something but
I don't know then again you know I
really looked into the situation I don't
really know what the free stuff you get
like even what obviously it's not free
you pay for legendary weapons XP boosts
packs exclusive founder packs things I
mean pretty much what they're probably
doing is they're like look you pay what
is it 89 for one key and 150 so they're
like you know if you get the regular
expansion and they're like we're pretty
much just giving you at a discounted
rate what these things would cost in the
free-to-play model so you know it's like
um I'm playing fable fortune it's a
preview program it's like for the $11
founder pack what's 15 but they give you
a discount when it first came out you
get 30 packs but then if you look how
much the packs in the actual store cause
it's like for that amount of packs it's
like $20 so you know that yeah they try
to get you in the initial you know the
revenue to keep the game flowing to keep
you know updating the game they try to
and you know it's like cactus say you
know you gotta play that devil's
advocate that you know I can understand
to listen but what I'm my issue is is
like you know if they if it was set in
stone if we only do this and know what
else tries I'd be okay with it but I
feel like maybe the industry might adopt
that I think that they should take the
gigantic model that game gigantic that
was in a preview program I downloaded it
it was for free I played the game
so you know they took my data I'm pretty
sure the game was released what I didn't
like was the game was released and is a
really good game is a very good game um
but there was no fanfare for the release
of the game that made it from the
preview program to an actual release and
it's a very very good game if you went
to that person of the PvP type of game
where you have different cartoon
characters and the art style is very
reminiscent of overwatch the characters
is very well developed like in an
overwatch style but this game is not
being promoted was promoted at 183
before I played it in the preview
program it was free and if they said now
you'll give me 15 bucks or whatever the
plate you know once I made it to market
yes I did so um and I was allowed to
play the game for free
I think the preview program should be
for free and then if the game is
released and you wasn't part of the
pre-boot program then you know you know
pay pay money for it whatever listen
we're gonna we gonna move this out a
week we've beaten this thing to death
you know basically you know my feelings
on it
all the Lords made great points crude
and low khakis I mean it's one of those
things you know I understand a point
with the smaller studios I understand
that they need
you know things as far as you know they
not have the resources and stuff like
that so you know I get it it's won and
ultimately it comes down to you vote
which a wallet if you don't want to
support the game when you don't think
it's something that you'll be interested
or you think it's anti-consumer don't do
it if you like the project you like you
know the art style where it's going you
know by all means plucky cash down the
process
you know those practices then you can't
you can't buy it so let's move on and
don't want to get this over to Lord
addict he's got to talk about season
passes and the way to handle them I had
a more in-depth topic but you know we're
going a little bit longer than we
normally do so I'm gonna make it real
real close you know just a simple topic
so you know obviously with season passes
there's the right way to do them then
there's the wrong way to do and you know
a lot of people speculate if you buy
season pass to a gang like let's say
destiny then
you know XCOM is another one they've
recently brought up that you should get
every content that's ever released for
that so I just want to like you know go
around and you know ask you guys what's
a good example and do you think that you
know that statement should be true like
for instance you know the season pass
for destiny one where you know after
everything with the first two expansions
you had to pay separately for do you
think they should have been part of the
season pass or do you think that you
know there should be another season pass
because I remember correctly after the
second one you didn't get they didn't
offer another season pass you had to pay
for them individually also you know if I
were you know I'll go first since it's
my topic you know there's games like you
know Halo Wars to you know people know
I'm a huge advocate of a great example
of season pass you know they have six
months of constant content you know then
you have on that opposite side of you
know as much as I go go at Bethesda
where you know they feel like we're
gonna give you a season pass and give
you huge amounts of content every three
or four months and what kind of you know
see because a lot of people have
problems with the white season passes
work in this industry right now what is
a way that you think would you you would
do it if you were in charge of that
aspect in the gaming industry let's get
let's get a look cactus in on this as
far as season passes in his own what
curious about his whole feel on that and
the right way the wrong way to do it
well I mean it is a people forget it's a
season's pass and not a forever pass so
like something like that's pretty
they're pretty clear it was like first
two expansions if I'm gonna get the dark
below and you'll get the House of wolves
I don't know why everyone was like so
shocked they didn't get a third
expansion that wasn't me whatsoever when
they bought the season's pass so like I
think at that point you're being a
little bit unreasonable it's like dude
it was pretty clear what the seasons
past was it was the two expansions at a
discounted price um now of course the
good thing is like honestly for someone
like me and like even looking at deci -
I'm all for the seasons pass I get both
pensions I already hundred percent know
I'm gonna get those two expansions like
III there's no way I'm not gonna get
them so I just get some cheaper so I'm
I'm going to
at the same time you know the bad part
is like you're putting a lot of faith
potentially in a developer that
sometimes you don't know like if you're
just selling destiny it's like well you
know I don't know maybe I'm not gonna
like this game by the time the first
expansion rolls around and or I'm not
gonna be playing it or gonna be playing
a different game so that's why seasons
pastas are even invented is they want to
lock you in they want to get your money
now because there's a chance that when
the first expansion comes guess what
you're in the Call of Duty World War two
you don't care about destiny anymore
well you've already bought the seasons
past so that's the point of it but again
if you're really invested in the game
like you know if you're a huge desti fan
you're getting you're getting it cheaper
like it's a good deal for you um yeah
they're season passes I've gone wrong
there's season passes that have gone I
think the first one that I was like oh
this is a good season pass was the
battlefield premium yeah amazing good
it's a lot of content for a smaller
price you got a ton of content it was
the price of like a whole nother game
but you got a bunch of expansions new
weapons and all of those expansions
priority you know and in queues and
stuff and and a couple other things and
you know that that was that was done
well and it was another thing where I
mean oh well it's interesting cuz
battlefield one like I got premium for
baffled one cuz I legitimately enjoy the
game but they're taking their sweet time
with those expansions and the next
expansion for the name of the Czar is
coming out in September well guess what
also comes out in September destiny
forget to Helen on battlefield one not
really really gonna play it but that's a
that's a pretty interesting aspect of
like did I just overpay I literally
might have cuz we're taking so long to
get these expansions out but yeah at the
end of the day again is the choice of
the consumer if you're really into a
game and you think you're going to be
like there for the long haul at Dusty's
a great example like if you love dusty
and you're psyched for destiny - that's
a good expansion by but otherwise
outside potentially take the $5 hit to
buy both differently to make sure you
want to buy the expansion or exactly
other good ideas like just before the
first expansion comes out if you're
still really into the game
then you could buy these season's pass
to get the discount fair enough I will
only endorse someone to pick up a season
pass that they know for a fact that
they're down with that franchise it's
like absolutely because you got you got
bad practices like you know I've been
told a lot of people don't like the way
Gears of War 4 did it to where to be
money to check he's saying a lot of
people saying they don't like the way
Forza does it they're pissed that like
they don't and then and then look at it
from that perspective of like you know
what fallout 4 first came out there like
we will give you a season pass and Bui
gonna tell you what you're doing that's
let's be when I'm up quick example of a
bad season pass that like disgusted you
that you were like disgusted by seasons
pass because I actually read them before
have you ever be have you ever been wild
though like what I kind of remember is
Borderlands 2 I think they um they had
their season's pass and then they had
like I think it was like it was just
like a level booster is like 10 more
levels and and a couple of other things
it wasn't a full expansion
and it was like it was like five dollars
or something right or ten dollars like
and it wasn't a full expansion and then
they wanted to charge people extra I
think who didn't like you bought the
season pass and you had to pay extra
like a five to four ninety-nine extra to
get this this thing maybe it was like
the MEC romancer I can't remember
exactly what it was but it was something
that you know they didn't have to do it
because it wasn't you know technically
technically it wasn't outlined in the
season's pass but it was like a smaller
thing like again one more character it
was like okay you know what throw a bone
deer season's pass owner is the perfect
thing to give to your season's pass
owners who just spent like thirty
dollars you know saying that they have
faith in their developer just kind of
she's pretty much bought your game
almost twice yeah just like it was the
exact opposite of what dasi did with the
taken king where the taking king was
like a massive expansion like bigger
than you know basically the other two
come before it was very reasonable to
say ya know this is like a little bit
beyond the seasons
this was kinda opposite where is so
small I was like okay guys throw it in
like you guys are being a little change
the entire perspective exactly that
expands exactly
alright thanks okay cuz I'll keep my
shirt so we can keep moving I think for
me I've always I'm I'm a guy like season
passes so I mean if it's if it's
something if it's a game that I really
passionate about I love I'm gonna commit
to it however like Laura Attucks
mentioned early like example of a bad
season pass to me was for life fall out
for because I didn't like the fact that
number one you know you didn't tell me
what was come in future content like
he's give me a romantic an example that
I feel does it well was like division
they told me exactly you're gonna get
this you're gonna get last and you get
your survival you're gonna you know you
don't even have to give me the specific
dates and I believe we went through this
before you know in an ILP topic you know
I don't even have to have the
specifically loans I have like a quarter
or a timeframe summer that kind of thing
did it feel like they would have mob
so he said uh-oh see in the bag and
whatever comes your way you'll be happy
you know what we messed up thirty
dollars wasn't enough a perfect example
the opposite of that again is with
battlefield
they're like boom he's in these five
expansions like and they had like
concepts for all of them like the like
you're getting at a Russian expansion
you're gonna get this expansion they're
each gonna contain new maps new weapons
and stuff like they're pretty clear
honey is like it was still ambiguous and
he didn't know exactly what you're
getting but you kind of did though like
you knew the contents of a battlefield
expansion there wasn't any like
weirdness whereas they yeah we fallout 4
is like hugely different
I mean shout out the Lord High bot so in
a chat I mean but Dez did that the host
fallout 4 thing it was like yeah we
ain't gonna tell you what you're gonna
get but if you don't buy it now we're
gonna raise the price felt like I was
pressured because but if you don't buy
this season pass that we're not telling
you specifically what's gonna be in it
just trust us because we're Bethesda we
all
we make great content you know to their
defense they always usually make you
know triple a confer but you know we
wanted me what I need underwhelming yes
including the whole game shot 33.5 I
like to call destiny one thing because
needlepoint like yeah absolutely I koala
for was a horror show when it came to
how they handle that and yeah the the
DLC was not fallout three caliber DLC
absolutely was not and then when you go
into the season pass for doom for Doom
they dooms this great single-player
experience and the season passes
entirely multiplayer beta nobody cared
about like nobody get about to the point
where now because game everything free
um it's like a 60 gigabyte download of
multiplayer stuff that nobody wants but
I mean whatever they should have had
single player DLC for that now to the
but that's the defense it seems like
they're getting it together in that
regard now because they just announced
the season pass for Wolfenstein the new
Colossus I mean telling you what's in it
Louis are we gonna know exactly what's
in it exactly they have been given three
separate campaigns little sideshow
campaigns that feature three different
protagonists not Legion blaskowitz does
not beat their blaskowitz and it just
seems interesting but they're telling
you what it is they it's obviously that
they're working on and already because
they have the story down they know what
they're gonna do with this um and again
it's something that if you like
Wolfenstein it being like what they've
done in the past two games it's
something that's gonna be attractive to
you and it ain't even use they given you
they haven't really set a release
cadence which is another thing that I
like to have with my season passes that
you tell me around about time when it's
coming yes
exactly but at the very least I have a
roadmap and I see okay is this stuff
that I'm gonna be invested in and if
again again if you're like if you like
the Wolfenstein story you're gonna
you're probably gonna be invested in
this DLC well I'm gonna at 4k sixty
I'm in the camp of some games don't need
this season pass time you know some
games do and some games just don't I
love my fighting games alright um I
purchase injustice doubt among us and
just as God among us to you know take in
all these all these and dig our season
passes why are you holding back
characters in a game where we got Mortal
Kombat 3 and Mortal Kombat 4 and those
games gave you every character yeah
fifty men rosters you know Tekken has 60
man rosters they released all of them
time releases or whatever however they
did it but now is behind this little pay
wall that I don't get certain characters
and that I gotta pay for in a fighting
game which kind of pisses me off I can
see in the open-world game where you
opening up other parts of the map and
you know as far as fallout goals yeah
they kind of gangsta with these stuff
and I pay for they are they a season
pass some season passes I got to the
point where I was a habitual season pass
purchaser out of fear of losing out
no-foam oh absolutely yeah order the
whole game let me get the whole game
it's some games I've never touched this
season pass like what the stuff came out
sex it's sex this is disgusting that we
feel as consumers that if we don't get
it now that the Bethesda thing rub me
it's completely the wrong way I'll never
forget the day Cardinal told me their
oldest piece about something oh yeah
I'll pick it up right before comes out
he said no no no no no tomorrow at noon
it's 60 bucks I said what he said yes
$30 now but tomorrow at noon is 60 bucks
yes so absurd that they did I had to
purchase right then in there mm-hm
and I never felt more pressure than as a
gamer you know Wow from right there's
like
either put up a shut up and you know
either you know being a be left out and
shout out the Lord anchorman he's always
you know screaming the praises a
Bethesda he's a true Bethesda head they
give great parties but they give of
their season passes just said they're
you know they getting this stuff
together maybe the backlash of us
talking about it and you know people
voting with their dollars didn't like
the practices of the last season pass
and this season pass gives you a better
description like they said we got a hope
what I dollars but I'm a hot [ __ ] you
will see the past purchaser without even
touching the content some the best
season pass ever I think which is the
widget three Wow yes sir absolutely
so let's get everything in we gonna
slowly wrap this thing up so now we went
a little bit overlooked kept like a kiss
a little later but um yeah I just wanted
to drill discuss the new poll that I
want to talk about this week we're gonna
in this thing off basically it's just
inspired by Lord Sovs topic and of
course destiny too so this is gonna be
put up on the ILP Twitter and it's gonna
be the questions gonna be this will a
first-person shooter
made in 2017 and beyond running at 30
frames per second stop you from
purchasing it so I need the people's
opinion on it you know it's a very
contentious topic so make sure you guys
hit the polls and we're gonna hit that
back up off for next week as far as the
results but um thank everyone for a
great show Lord cactus man thanks for
coming through and really appreciate you
in uh
wicking the UH we're gonna find people
find the king of the north the destiny
king of the north that's what I'm
calling it
well YouTube
Takas HD that's pretty self-explanatory
twitch same thing caucus HD Twitter a
trick caucus yeah no one falls me on
Twitter so you all should do that
they said you got any anything cooking
up that we should pay attention to we
love those exotic family exotics man I
mean your content so great
wanna know if any anything else recently
czar cooking up that we should be on the
capsule the last episode the like final
episode of family exhaust is coming next
Saturday I think we're winding it down
just because like destiny to it's kind
of outdated at this point yeah but I do
not know just kind of getting ready
getting prepared for for destiny to
really so like you know destiny to any
destiny to news like important stuff
that comes out definitely I'll be
covering it and I think I'm gonna take
part of the in the PC beta as well I
just want to like really see how that
runs and so that's gonna be exciting and
of course now it's getting close to the
full game the only other thing I guess
is I record the script I got to get
gameplay as much as I don't want to but
the ultimate crucible guide a parody
guide part 2 is coming out and it's
gonna be it's gonna be savage it's gonna
say that it's good there's gonna be so
many singers you guys aren't even be
able to keep track I'm so excited
because I love your content always speak
your mind you know you one of the
pioneers out there was great to chop it
up which you ain't Guardian con and um
yeah man I mean this this Lord I had one
of the best conversations we're just
talking destiny and it was just really
cool and like I said you always welcome
on the IOP anytime you want man true
true blue guy this guy loved khakis so
of course the usual suspects are you
gonna wrap up Lord addict where can the
fine people find you and what's going on
with that attics show and that gaming
addict chatter are you really done
nothing with that stuff man
like I keep going at people in my
comment sections I usually don't let
them get to me but here the past couple
of days man like they've been coming at
me so you know I definitely go be making
a genetic spotlight on the beta for
destiny too
pretty soon I'm still getting that
together you can follow me on YouTube
gaming addict you follow me on Twitter
Lord addict I LP you know anchorman
loves saying I'm the person with many
identities I don't know why but you know
I do you know I definitely want to take
a minute out you know let me tell you
about cactus HD this man has no business
being on this podcast with us you know
he's definitely you know we are way out
of his reach you know I got I got to
take a second and you know thank this
man for coming on here
you know know he got a lot of people in
his rage are very you know very
exclusive you got to be in their click
to really mess with them but you know
not HD you know podcasts do hope you
found even if you guys don't follow
destiny this man does a lot of other
content you know I encourage you to
follow month caucus HD follow his
channel that great stuff and not just
destiny stuff also for the people that
the destiny aiders he does looters it's
mostly destiny right now is mostly
destiny listen well I was I was major
trying that you know you do branch out
yeah like just quickly uh anthem
remember at e3 that game that's
something I'm definitely looking at nice
nice now if division comes out with a
sequel will you be a covering as well
maybe I deserve it was a fun game like
it was a legitimately fun game I just it
just didn't have the staying power of
destiny and some of the extractions were
vastly more underwhelming than others
like the the latest expansion came out
it's all focused on PvP in a dark zone
I'm not really into that so I just
wasn't really into that expansion you
get some good things but at the end of
the day I think dusty just had more
staying power yeah yeah but you know
it's like I said you know I always been
following cactus HD I might not agree
with all of his videos
oh but he's definitely solid and yeah I
appreciate you coming
absolutely and uh Lord sovereign say my
xbox offline profile is gonna be online
this week and as always the good people
could find me or not find me on Xbox
Live bxr and PSN bx7 one word and on
Twitter Lord saw IOP yeah and if you
know you try to send them a party if I
don't get offended cuz you don't even
join the my father Lord sometimes a
single play experience reason King we
can define people find you I would like
to say uh locust thank you for showing
up I watched a couple of your videos
yesterday and like I said I followed you
on Twitter um you know so but you can
find me on Facebook Instagram Twitter
YouTube Oh
PSN the tag is Xbox 360 lover boy
console troll realness we always telling
you not necessarily what you would hear
but what you need so please hit that
like subscribe on the ILP all our media
outlets YouTube iTunes SoundCloud all
that support really helps us you know
the Lord is much appreciated we've got a
lot of good things cooking up some
surprises you know for the people that
you guys might get excited and again we
want to thank our Lord cactus one last
time for coming through and hopefully we
see them again so on that note we're
gonna end this thing and we're out peace